[Music]
welcome to the ark of life with peter
singer
peter singer is a world-renowned moral
philosopher founder of the charity the
life you can save
peter is known for his work on applied
ethics especially issues surrounding
animal rights and global poverty where
he works from a secular
utilitarian perspective a prolific
author
peter is known in particular for his
1975 book
animal liberation considered the
founding philosophical statement
of the animal liberation movement his
new book
why vegan is being released later this
month
thank you so much for joining us thank
you jenny it's a pleasure to be with you
um maybe we can start with most
philosophers
can expect to wait generations for their
ideas
to gain traction and make a real
difference in the real world
what is it about your ideas do you think
that has meant that you've seen so many
changes in connection with them in your
lifetime
i suppose uh it's been timely i suppose
i
i wrote animal liberation just at the
time when people were ready to start
thinking
radically about our relationships with
animals uh it was after all the
seventies people had
already started thinking more radically
about issues like uh
race and about the position of women uh
about uh
gay rights and perhaps it was time for
them to think radically about
animals and in terms of global poverty
actually i i had to wait a while i think
for my views which i first
wrote in published in 1972 and although
they they had some impact but
it's really the rise of the effective
altruism movement
just you know barely a decade old now um
so
i did have to wait uh fortunately i'm
still around and could see it happen
maybe we should begin by talking about
that the effective altruism movement
utilitarianism is having a moment now
really with the effective altruism
movement
what do you think is its appeal today
uh first just let me say that while
certainly i think all utilitarians
should be effective altruists
you don't have to be a utilitarian to be
an effective altruist um you know
you might be a uh an effective altruist
because you're a christian and you might
think there are some things that you
ought never to do but otherwise you want
to help people
um and that's certainly i'm sure we have
many such people who are effective
altruists
why is it why is it having a moment uh
today though
uh it's it's hard to say but some of it
certainly has to do with the internet
uh i think there were always people who
thought gee shouldn't we really be
helping people in great need shouldn't
we be trying to do the best we can
why are we tending to think about this
narrow
self-interested view not even really
genuinely self-interested i think but
this material self-interest
of i need to earn more money i need to
have a better car i need to have a nicer
house
and but i think those people tended to
be isolated and they thought gee am i
the only one thinking like that is there
something wrong with me
but because of the internet people could
get together from all over the world and
find that there are
lots of like-minded people and the other
thing that they could do because of the
internet is
they can make use of research done by
others
on which are the most effective
charities and so there's this lively
ongoing discussion
about how to be an effective altruist
and there are
organizations like the life you can save
and give well
impact matters which are assessing uh
non-profits
to see which are the most effective and
that's been tremendously useful for the
movement
do you think part of the appeal is that
we're used to using
data to make decisions in this day and
age more and more and this is
an approach to doing good um that ties
in with that that ties into that spirit
of the age of ranking and measuring
effectiveness in terms of of how much
you can make your
your philanthropic buck go
yes i think that's a a good insight and
in fact it's interesting that one of the
organizations i just
mentioned uh givewell was started by
people who were working for a hedge fund
where their job was to analyze the data
as to which
companies their hedge fund ought to
invest in and then when they started
earning more money than they
really needed and started talking about
so which
charity should we donate it to and they
contacted several charities and found
they couldn't get the data you know the
charities just sent them
brochures with smiling pictures of
pictures of smiling children
and they said this is not what we want
we want hard data to know
what you would do with a thousand
dollars if i gave you that
uh and so they filled that void um so
yeah i think that that's
supports what you're saying that it's
data-driven
you've written about the moral
imperative to give is this famous uh
thought experiment about if you see a
child drowning
we believe that we we should jump in to
help even if we're wearing expensive
clothes
yet we're presented with an opportunity
to save a human life through a small
charitable donation we turn a blind eye
particularly if
it's somebody on the other side of the
world that we feel that we have no
connection to
in terms of of what is moral is ignoring
a flyer from a really effective charity
morally
the same as ignoring a drowning child
and walking on by
well certainly it's not emotionally the
same
because seeing the child in front of you
uh does have a strong appeal
um and in a sense you know so i was
playing with the fact that
there is that emotional peer appeal and
that you know
just about everyone would say of course
i would jump into the pond you know it's
a shallow pond you're not gonna drown
so of course you know you can't compare
the cost of some clothes with the
child's life they say
but when you actually look at the
consequences
and as a utilitarian i do think about
the consequences in deciding what's
right and wrong
then the consequences of not giving if
you know that
this is a really effective organization
if you know that for the cost of your
expensive clothes you could save a
child's life or
you could uh prevent somebody becoming
blind uh
then um i think there is there is a more
a sense in which uh it's just as bad
not to help the distant stranger as it
is
not to save the child do you see on a on
a practical level how difficult
that would be for for most people to
swallow to disentangle the emotional
from the moral
of course and i have to say that if i
you know some friend told me oh you know
today i just walked past a child who was
drowning in a shallow pond because i
didn't want to ruin my clothes
i don't think i could that person could
be a friend of mine at all
whereas i'm sure many of my friends
regrettably but still it's the case i
accept that they don't give
significantly to
effective charities so yes at a personal
level
it's really i i can understand uh that
it's very difficult to put these
things on the same moral level you do
give significantly to
too many charities do you think it's
possible to be a moral philosopher and
not practice what you preach in your
private life
uh it's obviously possible because there
are such people
um uh like a colleague of mine called
eric schwitzgable did a survey if you're
really interested in
finding that not all moral philosophers
are certainly not you know
morally superior in general to others
uh so it is possible but it's a puzzle
to me um especially if you're doing
uh applied ethics or practical ethics as
i'm doing you know maybe
if you're just interested in some much
more abstract question of theory
are moral judgments objectively true or
not
um maybe then that doesn't connect with
your
life but if you're doing practical
ethics and you're coming to conclusions
about what's the right thing to do for
that
not to have an impact on the way you
live would seem to
negate the point of what you're doing
you know why discuss these questions if
once you've got to the answer
it doesn't affect your behavior would
you
respect your colleagues less if they
didn't practice what they preached
uh yes i think there i could say yes
definitely less
your ideas are now being put into
practice they're being bankrolled
given the rocket fuel of billions of
dollars where you have big
philanthropists
deciding where to give according to
to principles that you've helped
originate does that put an extra
pressure on what you do
well i'm not the one telling them
generally you know where to give there
are organizations that
as i said are researching that and they
make their own decisions
about that so no i don't feel uh
pressure about that i
obviously the moral arguments that i've
put forward over many years
i'm glad that they're being acted on by
people who have the wealth
to make a big difference and i know some
of them have
read my work books like the life you can
say for example
and that that's led to them giving
substantial amounts so
i think that's great but um i try to
make my
writing as accurate and careful as it
can
so you know that's always been the case
i think really and
i don't think the fact that it's
affecting larger sums of money i i don't
feel that as pressure
in terms of the the effective altruist
approach which
which measures in many cases charities
in terms of the number of lives that
they can save
does it worry you at all that if this
would be
a revolution in our ideas of how to be
altruistic in a revolution
in philanthropy it would mean that there
would be no more funding for things like
the arts because you know how can you
justify funding an opera when there are
people dying does that worry you
i i don't agree that there would be no
more funding full stop for
for the arts what i think would happen
would be that
for a time more funding would go to the
providing the necessities of life to to
people but
it wouldn't really take a huge amount of
money
compared to what the gross national
income of the affluent countries
is to meet their basic needs
um so that we didn't have you know
millions or hundreds of millions of
people uh unable to get enough to eat or
living without decent sanitation or
not able to get basic health care we
could provide that for
maybe two or three percent of the gross
national product of the affluent world
and having done that we would still then
have funds to
fund the arts uh if if we wanted to and
i would hope that we would want to
uh once we'd met the more urgent needs
doesn't this kind of impro approach
imply that we should be focusing our
our attention on uh the consequences of
things like global inequality rather
than
dismantling the things that cause these
huge
inequalities doesn't capitalism corrupt
governments get a free pass with this
kind of approach of how to do good
well if you tell me you know your plan
for overthrowing capitalism and
replacing it with a better and fairer
economic system
i'm happy to look at that and if you
convince me that there's a real chance
that you're going to succeed in
in doing this then that might become a
very effective charity to donate to
but so far to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas